[Música]
son conocidos por sus grupos de
mercenarios bajo contrato su red de
extracción de diamantes y de
producciones cinematográficas así como
por respaldar a gobiernos autócratas
concursos de belleza y por estar
encargados de incrementar la influencia
o presencia de Rusia en el mundo
recientemente en llave con el ejército
ruso han participado en operativos
militares para conquistar zonas del este
de Ucrania provocando tensiones entre
ambas partes el grupo Wagner aumenta día
a día su presencia una presencia que
debe preocuparle al mundo veamos algunos
datos básicos el grupo Wagner
Aparentemente es financiado por el
gobierno ruso por el kremlin
Aparentemente ellos son quienes lo han
creado Aunque desde Moscú Siempre han
negado tener alguna conexión con este
grupo son un grupo de mercenarios
militares bien entrenados fuertemente
armados y muy buenos estrategas en
términos militares poseen varias
empresas que se encargan de Ocultar sus
operaciones militares o ser encargadas
de Buscar recursos para mantenerlos
además incursionaron en el negocio de la
desinformación y de la propaganda en las
redes sociales y los medios de
comunicación algo en lo que los rusos
son bastante buenos
en cuanto a las empresas fachadas
tenemos desde concursos de belleza como
ya les decía hasta mineras que están
encargadas de la extracción de diamantes
en diferentes países de África también
hay empresas importadoras empresas de
seguridad productores audiovisuales ya
cuentan con su primer largometraje en el
que hablan precisamente de las
operaciones de este grupo en algunos
países africanos su fin es aumentar la
influencia de Rusia en el mundo por
ahora su foco parece estar en África
pero inicialmente fueron lideradas por
Dimitri utkin una militar ruso que
perteneció a las fuerzas especiales de
ese país su primera operación militar
tuvo lugar en el año 2014 en la del
donbas allí apoyaron a los ejércitos
separatistas de las regiones de
donnietsk y lugansk en 2015 se
expandieron hacia Siria Para apoyar al
presidente sirio bachar alazad su misión
ayer era prácticamente recuperar las
zonas que son ricas en recursos
naturales principalmente en petróleo y
gas y en 2017 tiene lugar un paso muy
importante y es la incursión en África
una operación que fue liderada por Jake
Benny brigation quien es actualmente el
líder de este grupo Allí se enfrentaron
en el norte de mozambique contra grupos
yihadistas entonces En qué países tienen
presencia pues principalmente están en
Mali burkina faso Camerún Libia Sudán la
República centroafricana en donde
protegen personalmente al presidente de
ese país que está inmerso en una
profunda Guerra Civil mozambique
Madagascar la República democrática del
Congo zimbabue Sudáfrica Siria Y por
supuesto Ucrania el mismo pregosing ha
negado cualquier tipo de relación con el
grupo Wagner incluso ha dicho que es una
leyenda urbana y ha puesto en entredicho
su existencia pero luego lo vimos unas
semanas más adelante o tiempo después
hablando de los triunfos que han tenido
en el este de Ucrania pero la reciente
participación justamente de Wagner en
ataques en Ucrania preocupa por el tono
que puede adquirir Entonces esta guerra
siendo la presencia de estos mercenarios
un factor para que se prolongue este
conflicto en el tiempo también es
preocupante su presencia en África Rusia
lucha para ganar allí posiciones de
privilegio ante la extensa presencia de
países como china como Turquía como los
emiratos árabes Unidos y Qatar pero
Rusia lo hace protegiendo gobiernos
autocráticos explotando las riquezas
africanas y apoyando a las fuerzas
armadas de algunos de los conflictos más
largos en ese continente debe Entonces
el mundo preocuparse por este ejército
en las sombras lo vamos a analizar hoy
en el debate de France 24 para conversar
sobre este tema hemos invitado a
Vladimir rubinsky él es profesor de
ciencia política y relaciones
internacionales de la universidad y Ceci
Y también está con nosotros Fernando
cocho él es analista de inteligencia y
riesgos de seguridad nacional a nuestros
televidentes les recuerdo que también
hacen parte de este debate pueden dejar
todos sus comentarios y sus preguntas a
través de las redes sociales estamos en
Twitter en Facebook También estamos en
instagram no se encuentran como arroba
el
debate_f24 arroba santilogo y la
etiqueta para que dejen los comentarios
es numeral el debate f24 no se olviden
también que los contenidos de nuestro
programa están disponibles en Apple
podcast en Spotify en deezer y en TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la palabra a
Vladimir dándole la bienvenida al
programa Vladimir Gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa y retomo alguna
de las frases que estaba diciendo la
introducción este grupo Wagner es una
leyenda como lo quieren hacer ver es un
ejército en las sombras que
Aparentemente No existe o si existe Y si
está ligado al kremlin
Muchas gracias por la invitación no ya
no es una leyenda
precisamente hace unas semanas el mismo
dueño de esta empresa o posiblemente son
posiblemente son varias empresas pero sí
existen
fue confirmado el hecho de la existencia
por el mismo y el Jenny pregocen Ya
hasta tiene un centro de reclutamiento
en la ciudad de San Petersburgo y ya
pasó de esa época cuando estaba operando
en una zona completamente gris donde el
mismo gobierno ruso estaba llegando su
presencia hasta que hoy en día aparecen
en las pantallas de la televisión en
Rusia les hacen Gloria por sus éxitos en
el campo de combate y prácticamente
Jenni pregocen se volvió figura muy
pública hoy en día gracias a la
participación del grupo Wagner en en
Ucrania
y Fernando le doy la bienvenida también
al programa y le y le pregunto si esto
para usted Sigue siendo una leyenda
claramente Este grupo ya existe con
operaciones en diferentes países
retomo este tema de la leyenda porque
así lo dicen algunos medios rusos y así
lo han dicho algunos medios en occidente
Y qué necesidad tiene Rusia de crear
este ejército en las sombras este
ejército paralelo
buenas tardes buenas noches Aquí en
España Gracias por invitarme al programa
bien Santiago el problema está en que lo
que se ha hecho Durante los años 60 70 y
principios de los 80 por parte de otros
países otros gobiernos recordemos la
década de los 60 y 70 el gobierno
sudafricano
donde está vinculado incluso Gran
Bretaña lo que hacían en otros momentos
otros países tener este grupo de pmcs de
militares privados empresas militares
privadas por favor
vinculado a Estados Unidos pues lo que
ha hecho Rusia ha sido darle un punto
más generando lo que se llama un negocio
de publicidad
utilizando las redes sociales utilizando
los medios de información y
desinformación para hacer No solo una
acción de mercenarios personal militar
al servicio de que lo pueda contratar
este caso los intereses rusos sino
además hacerlo de una manera totalmente
transparente totalmente
intentando hacerlo como un trabajo más
como una empresa lícita que está
resolviendo problemas y protegiendo
información o protegiendo personalidades
pozos de petróleo gas etcétera ahorro
del mundo pero lo que hacen en África
básicamente es proteger dictaduras y
proteger los intereses no solo de Rusia
sino de otros caciques otros miembros de
oligarcas rusos Y eso es lo más
importante que es un ejército privado al
servicio de un país pero también el
servicio de una élite política y civil
que también los contrata Fernando hay
conocimiento de cómo se financia
exactamente esta empresa privada si está
esto en conexión con el kremlin es el
kremlin el que destina el dinero para
mantenerlos aparte de este negocio que
como usted dice tratan de mostrarlo como
un negocio lícito contratados por por un
gobierno por una empresa para hacer un
trabajo en específico como más se se
financian porque tienen acceso a armas a
equipos de inteligencia a equipos
también para desplazarse como aviones
helicópteros
quien le suministra todo esto De dónde
viene todo este equipamiento
hasta hasta febrero del 2021
eran financiados y patrocinados y
obtenían armamento y tecnología por
parte de la federación rusa en este caso
el urs o SV Perdón o otros etcétera Pero
a partir de ese fecha se han convertido
una empresa privada absolutamente que
obtiene información de manera totalmente
legal con entidades unidades de
inteligencia contratadas a lo largo del
mundo con especialistas de todo el mundo
y se ha convertido
operaciones encubiertas aparatos de
propaganda de información y han
construido incluso al tener unas
oficinas spetesburgo sin ningún tipo de
pudor al asimilar que en otras épocas se
hizo por tanto antes de financiar
exclusivamente de financiaron el
servicio ruso ahora se financian con las
propias acciones de contratar sus
servicios por parte de otras empresas
incluso empresas de lo que se llaman la
anglosfera decir No solo trabaja por
servicio ruso para los intereses rusos
sino también incluso para
multinacionales francesas
norteamericanas británicas Aunque suene
muy extraño se ha convertido en una
empresa más de servicios entre los
cuales está la información está la
inteligencia está los análisis de
riesgos políticos geoeconómicos pero
también el ejército
Vladimir retomó la comunicación con
usted para preguntarle Entonces ya
habiendo entendido este ejército De
dónde viene y cómo se está financiando
cuál sería Entonces el interés del
kremlin de crear esta corporación porque
es una es un gran grupo a nivel
comercial con diferentes líneas de
negocio como lo estaba mencionando yo en
la introducción del programa hasta
producciones cinematográficas tiene
financia también concursos de belleza en
algunos países africanos cuál sería
entonces la estrategia rusa detrás de
todo esto
bueno como usted me mencionó
precisamente grupo Wagner o varias
empresas probablemente que están bajo el
nombre o conocidos bajo el nombre del
grupo Wagner es un conglomerato que
tiene intereses en distintos aspectos De
esta zona gris donde opera el gobierno
de Vladimir Putin y Jenny tiene una
trayectoria bastante interesante en los
tiempos de la unión soviética pasó casi
diez años en una cárcel luego en la
década noventa con esas transformaciones
en la unión en Post Unión soviética en
esta Rusia se volvió uno de los amigos
bastante cercanos a Vladimir Putin y sus
negocios en la década noventa
interesante era parte de una cadena de
los restaurantes pero donde estuvieron
reuniendo todos los actores claves de la
política y de negocios de San
Petersburgo en la década así se volvió
una persona muy cercana a Vladimir Putin
en sus restaurantes incluso tenían
escenas de almuerzos hasta los
precedentes de los Estados Unidos en su
momento y cuando puchen el precisamente
decide que necesita tener una arma muy
flexible Para poder ejercer las tareas
que el ejército ruso por una otra razón
no tiene capacidad eso no no está
posicionado para ejercer mejor entonces
aparece el grupo Wagner que comienza sus
aterraciones en África en Siria de hecho
una de las primeras tareas antes donde
sabemos fue proteger los barcos
allá en el océano indio cuando estaban
atacandolo por la ferretería y ahora
están involucrados en todo lo que es
necesario pero sobre todo en este
momento es una arma es una herramienta
más bien clave para poder avanzar lo que
Rusia está haciendo en Ucrania Vladimir
estaríamos ante una nueva generación
oligarcas rusos porque recordemos que
los primeros oligarcas que existieron en
en este país enriquecieron a través de
las acciones de las empresas estatales
cuando fueron privatizadas pero esta
sería una nueva generación de personas
muy ligadas al tema militar Y al igual
que los oligarcas anteriores muy
cercanos al gobierno de turno en Moscú
siendo parte también de la estrategia
del gobierno de turno para mantenerse en
el poder como lo vio usted
hay varios temas que hay que tener en
cuenta en primer lugar Me parece muy
importante
que usted mencionó Santiago ahora es
sobre la posibilidad de hacer un negocio
algo que hará impensable en los tiempos
de la unión soviética y con todos los
servicios de la inteligencia de los
servicios especiales que sabemos que
eran muy fuertes por parte de la unión
soviética pero prácticamente nunca tenía
posibilidad de realmente comenzar ganar
unos millones de dólares en este caso
hay un negocio Es una posibilidad debido
a su cercanía al gobierno de Vladimir
Putin debido a las tareas que están
ejerciendo el grupo Wagner otros
básicamente lo que nosotros tenemos que
matan muchos pájaros con un solo tiro
Rusia avanza con sus tareas en Ucrania o
puede avanzar en sus operaciones
especiales de información en el Internet
pero en el mismo tiempo las personas que
están a cargo de estas operaciones se
vuelven cada vez en las personas más
ricas Porque estos recursos que pasan
por estos rubros del presupuesto son
secretos son cerrados Entonces no hay
ninguna forma de saber ni rendir las
cuentas
claro y aquí transparencia hay una
fachada transparente y se ven como una
corporación establecida como cualquier
entidad comercial pero a la hora de ver
los números y la financiación del Estado
Ahí es donde empiezan a ver aún más
sombras Fernando Quiero preguntarle por
los hechos recientes los hechos de las
últimas semanas y es que fue dado a
conocer algo que tal vez era un Secreto
a voces y es la presencia de mercenarios
de Wagner en el este de Ucrania
reforzando las operaciones del ejército
ruso esto que nos puede indicar a nivel
militar que claramente el ejército ruso
está en en un mal momento a nivel de
táctico o a nivel de recursos y
necesitaba ser reforzado por este
ejército privado para cumplir sus
operaciones en el este de Ucrania o
cómo entender esta esta presencia de
este ejército privado en este conflicto
Bueno lo primero que comprender Es que
la doctrina militar tradicional rusa que
es muy anticuada piensa que en
Infantería no es importante y se ha
basado siempre en artillería y en la
Aviación básicamente artillería pesada y
Aviación El problema es que en esta
Guerra de Ucrania se ha demostrado que
esa doctrina ha quedado obsoleta ante
movilidades más rápidas acciones más
flexibles o incluso con herramientas o
armamento más ligero en ese caso se
necesita por parte del ejército ruso una
unas unidades preparadas o las unidades
sea flexibles que ya han demostrado su
eficacia desde 2014 el donbas el lugars
y demás para o ayudar a los grupos
separatistas prorusos y entonces
utilizan estas herramientas que en este
caso ese grupo Wagner para llegar a
hacer lo que la doctrina oficial lo que
las tropas de reemplazo para entendernos
no son capaces de hacer y han demostrado
si no es un fracaso si su detrimento
constante es decir Putin puede soportar
un volumen determinado de pérdidas Es
cierto que hay unas pensamiento ya más
crítico dentro de lo que es el kremlin
por tanto claro que el grupo Wagner lo
que ha conseguido es apoyar en
Infantería especializada lo que ha
demostrado Putin no poder hacer
Infantería tradicional que como hemos
visto los medios de comunicación Pues
estaba fallando esos objetivos y este es
el objetivo principal Fernando Pero
entonces esto confirma que el ejército
ruso no le está yendo tan bien como el
kremlin quiere demostrar y también como
algunos medios occidentales
mostrábamos que había grandes avances de
Ucrania y éramos criticados justamente
por estar de un lado de un bando del
otro Esto sí confirmaría Entonces que
Rusia no está siendo tan exitosa en
terreno como se está como ellos lo hacen
ver
obviamente es es un hecho objetivo Y
además palmario que Rusia no ha
conseguido sus objetivos del primer
momento que se plantearon para los que
fuesen porque no conocimos su doctrina
secreta
en lo que es Ucrania obviamente pero eso
no significa que Rusia esté mucho menos
vencida o haya perdido toda su capacidad
militar Lo que pasa que es equivocado
prácticamente en lo que era una guerra
moderna desde una guerra tradicional que
ha intentado obviamente
ha perdido lo que es la parte por
supuesto informativa y la parte de la
Infantería y mucho territorio que
esperaba no perder también ha perdido
Pero eso no significa que Rusia esté
vencida claro no la guerra sigue y los
combates continúan el hecho que no hayan
tenido éxitos tan inmediatos como como
ellos esperaban no quiere decir que
hayan perdido la batalla o la guerra por
completo siguen allí y el frente sigue
abierto Vladimir Quiero preguntarle por
uno de los puntos importantes de esta
corporación que es la desinformación y
la propaganda algo que como les decía yo
en la introducción del programa los
rusos son muy buenos a la hora de
hacerlo a la hora de de meterse en las
elecciones de países a través de de
movimientos por internet de las redes
sociales desinformando Qué información
hay sobre este tipo de sobre el grupo
Wagner y las operaciones que han tenido
lugar en en este ámbito saliéndonos un
poco del lado militar y de las
operaciones en Ucrania y entrando en
esta otra ala del negocio que es la
desinformación y la propaganda
en la Rusia de hoy existe un ecosistema
completo que está diseñado para llevar a
cabo las apelaciones de influencia o las
operaciones de información la propaganda
está muy bien vista por los líderes de
la Rusia contemporánea entonces una
parte de este ecosistema es precisamente
algo que puede ser manejado por las
empresas privadas tales como el grupo
Wagner y lo que es bien conocido pero
muchos expertos ahora olvidaron sobre la
Génesis de la agencia de investigaciones
del internet como llamaba esta empresa
de promoción en ese entonces que comenzó
a hacer la las operaciones del centro
formación dentro de la Rusia en primer
lugar contra la oposición y cuando
demostró su eficacia demostró que vale
la pena invertir los recursos en este
comienzo ya sus aterraciones en el
exterior es bien conocido lo que
hicieron en las elecciones de Estados
Unidos son dos mil dieciséis pero
básicamente continúan haciendo eh
continúan haciendo las informaciones en
las alteraciones de de esa información
en una coordinación Aparentemente con
otros entidades del gobierno ruso pero
otra vez hablando de las posibilidades
de poder ganar plata están ganando los
recursos están ganando los contratos del
gobierno para poder hacer esto Vladimir
voy a entrar en un terreno tal vez que
va a ser un poco especulativo Tal vez
hasta un poco conspirativo y creería yo
que rayando un poco a lo Hollywood Pero
estaría de pronto el presidente Putin
creando este sistema de propaganda
paralelo este sistema militar paralelo
pensando en un futuro en que las fuerzas
militares le den la espalda
rechacen las doctrinas que tienen en
este momento en torno al a la guerra en
Ucrania y también todo este sistema de
propaganda que ha creado el gobierno
ruso a través de diferentes agencias de
prensa y canales de noticia le de la
espalda y él pueda mantener un mecanismo
para seguir moviendo su imagen y
moviendo su su discurso entre los rusos
y también a nivel internacional
en este momento yo creo que el poder de
Vladimir Putin es muy firme no está
amenazado lo que sí efectivamente tiene
lugar y donde el mismo pregocen el grupo
Wagner están involucrados es en algunos
peles decimos de esa manera peleas
políticas que tiene lugar en el nivel de
las élites rusas que no cuestionan por
ahora o por lo menos lo que hace lo que
dice Vladimir Putin pero tratan de ganar
el espacio tratan de ganar la influencia
viendo que las cosas no van bien para
Rusia el mismo pregocen Está criticando
fuertemente a las fuerzas militares
rusas antes sería muy difícil pensar que
esto es posible pero lo está haciendo y
básicamente está actuando es el grupo
Wagner como un ejército privado pero que
rinde cuentas habla de mercurio en a
nadie más Porque existe un espacio gris
legalmente entonces hace lo que Vladimir
Putin les está ordenando hacer pero yo
creo que en este movimiento todo todo
por ahora para Putin está muy bien el
poder de allá en Rusia Sí Cuenta todavía
con el apoyo de muchos ciudadanos y de
muchos sectores políticos Fernando
Vladimir toca un punto importante y es
estas discrepancias o discusiones o
críticas que hay desde el grupo Wagner
hacia el ejército y viceversa hay
confrontaciones al interior de estas de
estos grupos militares justamente por
ponerse en el hombro las victorias
recientes que ha habido en el este de
Ucrania hablo puntualmente de las
victorias o la captura de soledad en el
este de Ucrania esto puede empezar a
generar tensiones y problemas en el en
el frente de batalla y puede volver esto
un conflicto no a dos bandas ucranianos
contra rusos sino a tres bandas
ucranianos contra Wagner contra ejército
ruso como lo ve usted
Sí además quiero hacer un hincapié en lo
que ha hecho el compañero el que usted
ha preguntado evidentemente es un
escrito en la sombra y evidentemente le
debe fidelidad a Putin pero no solo por
eso sino porque no olvidemos que Putin
cuando llegó al poder tanto como
presidente o Primer Ministro
alternativamente le dio prioridad a los
oligarcas a la mafia rusa que eran que
provenían
ellos porque él les apetezburgo entonces
a partir de ahí los oligarcas empezaron
a tener una tendencia mucho más fuerte
de esa orientación y el grupo Wagner ya
desde hace mucho tiempo no solo hizo
acciones de influencia dentro de Rusia
sino que allí donde el greu no podía
actuar Jorge Raúl no podía llegar a
disciplinar a los disidentes el grupo
Wagner se sospecha que sí ha estado
detrás de muchos de estos accidentes que
han ocurrido a lo largo de poco tiempo
sobre ligar caso segundas áreas de
funcionarios no no alineados sino
disidentes y evidentemente determinado
que esa ya vemos ejército privado de
élite de Putin tenga unos intereses
aliados con Putin y sea el garante de
continuar con el poder militar y el
poder no de inteligencia solo sino Poder
Ejecutivo en ciertas partes de Ucrania
en cuanto una guerra tres bandas
complicado porque el ejército ruso no es
del todo fácil de domesticar o fácil de
doblegar y que haya subido de disidencia
De hecho cuando hay disidencia Putin nos
ha detectar como buen experto en
inteligencia Y los quita de la primera
línea y lo sustituye por otros pensemos
en las los etcétera etcétera
Fernanda hablemos de las estrategias de
este grupo en en terreno en combate
puntualmente del caso de Ucrania también
en algunos combates en Siria se ha
criticado mucho o por lo menos así lo ha
dicho la prensa occidental del tipo de
tácticas que emplean que son sumamente
agresivas sanguinarias y que no
escatiman en poner en su primera línea
de frente la mayor cantidad de hombres
que sean necesarios y no les importa
perderlos en el combate perder en las
filas
con tal de llegar al objetivo y cumplir
con la misión que se les pide que se
sabe del combate en terreno de sus
tácticas militares
son las mismas tácticas militares que
los años 70-80 los llamados de la
anglosfera Estados Unidos y Gran Bretaña
utilizaron Francia utilizado en África
lo que pasa es que no daban esta
publicidad porque está muy mal vista
esto ha ocurrido siempre y estas
tácticas son las propias de un
mercenarios gente que no tiene ningún
tipo de roe de regla de reglas de
enfrentamiento aceptadas por las
comisiones de Ginebra y por cualquier
otra convención de lucha o de conflicto
militar Por tanto se rigen por
un solo
digámoslo así El Triunfo a cualquier
coste al igual que otras empresas por
ejemplo fueron condenadas en el Golfo de
biafra por la masacre de los ogoni y 35
años después fueron condenados
militarmente una petrolera pero
económicamente en la petrolera que nos
había contratado pero ya era muy tarde o
sea la ventaja que tiene Wagner es que
no solo hace lo que siempre se ha hecho
por parte de los pmc y Los mercenarios
sino que además lo divulga genera una
imagen y una reputación que les permite
granjearse más éxito comercial Sí hemos
visto varios vídeos en las redes
sociales incluso uno de pregon entre en
un sótano de un edificio en el este de
Ucrania rodeado de muchos cuerpos de sus
filas de hombres que murieron en
diferentes combates hablando de la
situación allí en el frente una escena
Pues que claramente uno no la ve por
parte de las fuerzas armadas de ningún
país no hacen propaganda de ningún tipo
de sitio y se mueve a través de las
redes rusas y llegan a occidente para
difundirlo Vladimir hablemos de la
posición que tiene Rusia en África ya
hemos hablado de lo que está haciendo
este grupo Wagner en el este de Ucrania
y la importancia que tiene para el
presidente Putin Pero qué hay de esa
presencia rusa en ese continente cuál es
la necesidad que tiene Rusia de llegar
allí a posicionarse en este ámbito
militar haciéndole competencia a países
que ya están muy bien parados a nivel
político a nivel comercial y económico
como china como Turquía o países incluso
más afines a nivel cultural como los
emiratos árabes y Qatar
hay varias razones detrás del interés
ruso hacia África en primer lugar hay
que decir que Rusia sí llegó un poco
tarde a esta fiesta allá en África de
las grandes potencias Por ejemplo si
comparamos con el retorno ruso hacia
América Latina que ocurre más rápido en
comparación lo que la unión soviética
estuvieron haciendo tanto en África como
en Latinoamérica pero en primer lugar
son los intereses políticos África las
élites rusas están viendo África como un
socio importante en la construcción por
lo menos desde la perspectiva discursiva
del discurso narrativa de la
construcción de este mundo multipolar
que Rusia ASUME el liderazgo de hacer
frente del orden internacional liderado
por los Estados Unidos pero también a
intereses comerciales los rusos conocen
muy bien sobre la en cuanto a los
recursos que tiene África
hay muchos otras oportunidades también
para fomentar ciertas inversiones rusas
por ejemplo en el sector energético
Entonces es un interés yo creo a largo
plazo y nosotros vamos a ver en el
futuro yo creo que el aumento de la
presencia tangible rusa en África y que
hay de la presencia de estos grupos
Wagner en América Latina hay evidencia
de esto
yo he leído varios informes Sin embargo
a mí me hace todavía dudar que hay una
presencia realmente muy fuerte de lo que
llamamos el grupo wagnar acá en América
Latina no no sé si hay o no hay porque
las referencias que estuvieron haciendo
por ejemplo a la presencia de algunos
uniformados armados con las armas
modernas por ejemplo en la frontera
entre Venezuela y Colombia Me parece que
hace referencia precisamente a ciertas
partes del ejército ruso de lo que los
rusos llaman los técnicos militares que
están apoyando o estuvieron apoyando al
gobierno de maduro en cuanto al
mantenimiento de las armas que maduro
Estaba comprando de Rusia pero más allá
por ahora a mí me parece que es
simplemente no hay presencia porque no
hay donde realmente aplicar estas
fuerzas Fernando algo que decir en torno
a la posible presencia de grupo del
grupo Wagner América Latina para ampliar
no no se llaman grupo Wagner realmente
los que están actuando en América Latina
recordemos que un equipo similar Aunque
tengan en unas tácticas y la misma
vivenciación y objetivos e incluso la
misma cantera de candidatos son los
grupos que van protegido al cartel de la
droga de los tres soles no entre Los
triples Soles que se sabe que están
protegidos por la mafia rusa y por
miembros de la ex ejército soviético de
alta especialización algunos de los
cuales se han pasado de Wagner al grupo
digamos de protección en Venezuela y en
otros países y del grupo de Venezuela a
Wagner por tanto hay un tránsito Aunque
oficialmente no tiene un nombre como tal
Pero sí hay unos cuantos asesores no son
los públicos como ha comentado el
compañero
antes y delincuentes en América Latina
está constatado en la triple frontera
estamos atado en Venezuela está
constatado en algunas partes de Colombia
está constatado en México en el sur de
México y está constatado también en
Nicaragua El Salvador y en algunos
países además por tanto no se llaman
grupo Wagner son mucho más reducidos
pero sí existen Fernando y entendiendo
que este grupo está siendo presencia
entonces en por ejemplo en Ucrania que
ya lo mencionamos pero también están
haciendo presencia en algunos de los
conflictos más largos que ha estado
viviendo África en las últimas décadas
justamente por ser esto un grupo privado
por ser un negocio Esto entonces sería
prácticamente una carta de garantía para
que estos conflictos se alarguen y se
prolonguen precisamente porque aquí hay
un negocio Millonario de por medio Más
allá de él siempre negocio de la guerra
sí es posible Lo que pasa que yo creo
que hay una táctica también que hemos
olvidado de el grupo Wagner en África y
es el desplazamiento de las antiguas
potencias militares y económicas que
geopolíticamente estaban exprimiendo
digámoslo así claramente África como
puede ser Gran Bretaña Estados Unidos
incluso Francia está siendo desplazadas
por el grupo Wagner en virtud de esas
formas diferentes de hacer estrategia
militar dado que las las élites
cuando Gran Bretaña Posiblemente no está
por la labor de seguir las mismas
tácticas que utilizarán en la década 70
y 80 y 90 con sus propios mercenarios
Aunque mucho más ocultos por tanto no
podemos olvidar que a lo mejor en lugar
de estar para que se prolonguen esos
conflictos de manera indefinida es para
que cambien de bando definitivamente y
sean los garantes y haremosle un escrito
paralelo de los que gobiernen como
títeres por parte del apoyo de Wagner
eso es una estrategia que en algunos
informes de inteligencias está empezando
a barajar por los acciones Wagner muy
específicas muy quirúrgicas en algunas
partes muy concretas del continente
africano en apoyo de ciertas milicias y
ciertos grupos con cierto intereses
económicos contra las potencias
geopolíticas tradicionales como Francia
Gran Bretaña etcétera no me quedan un
par de minutos para finalizar el
programa quiero que Vladimir y Fernando
hagamos las conclusiones y para esta
conclusión Les propongo la misma
pregunta para los dos y es si el mundo
Simplemente no le está prestando la
suficiente atención al avance que está
teniendo este grupo en los diferentes
regiones en los diferentes continentes y
esto es algo de lo que nos deberíamos de
preocupar ya en este momento y no en un
futuro cuando este grupo esté está este
un poco más expandido
debemos preocuparnos por la expansión de
este ejército privado ruso comienzo
entonces con Vladimir para esta
conclusión
para responder a esta pregunta yo creo
que en primer lugar hay que decir que el
grupo Wagner no es el único ejército
privado esto es una tendencia que uno
puede observar en varios otros países
del Mundo donde los gobiernos tratan de
delegar ciertas tareas para operar en
esta zona gris a los grupos privados a
Los mercenarios lo que pasa con el grupo
Wagner Esto sí nos debe preocupar en
este momento porque Aparentemente está
tomando demasiado importancia demasiado
control sobre ciertos aspectos incluso
que tiene que ver con el uso de la
fuerza por parte de Rusia y esto es
preocupante porque en otros lugares si
bien existen nuevamente algo parecido
como estos grupos pero me parece que no
están llegando Al mismo nivel de
influencia sobre el gobierno sobre los
tomadores de como en el caso de Rusia y
Fernando su opinión para el cierre
Totalmente de acuerdo con lo que ha
dicho el compañero debemos prestarle
mucha atención no estamos prestando
suficiente atención y es cierto que
están apareciendo grupos por todas
partes incluso de mercenarios europeos
que van a apoyar incluso a intereses de
otros países pero evidentemente la
diferencia es el grupo Wagner tiene una
difusión y una capacidad de control de
las élites políticas por su precisa
precisamente por darse la vuelta a la
tortilla por decirlo de alguna manera
que no en otros grupos mucho más
soterrados y de digamos mercenarios
tradicionales no habíamos visto hasta
ahora es decir el grupo de mercenarios
controle a quien le a quien le está
pagando no es algo que se ha visto hasta
ahora mientras que Wagner puede llegar
un momento determinado a ejercer una
influencia política demasiado fuerte
Pues a Fernando y a Vladimir les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros habernos explicado puesto en
perspectiva de analizado la situación de
este grupo privado cercano al gobierno
ruso Muchas gracias por haber estado con
nosotros en nombre el equipo técnico
también Les agradecemos a ustedes la
sintonía por haber estado con nosotros
la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Keyla maestre y la producción
de invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Muchas gracias sigan con France
[Música]